hey 42 here the world is pretty big and
incredibly diverse so whenever you're
somewhere and you think it can't get
much hotter or wetter or higher than
this it probably can so where are the
undisputed champions where are the most
extreme places first let's look at the
world's hottest place temperatures taken
with thermometers on weather stations
would have you believe that L is easier
in Libya with its highest recorded
temperature of 58 degrees C or Death
Valley in California with its record
high reading of 56 point seven degrees C
are the hottest places on earth but
according to new satellite imagery data
they're not even serious contenders
there is a salt desert in the east of
Iran that's about 480 kilometers wide
and 320 wide called dashed e loot which
as of recently is officially the hottest
place on earth the surface of the sand
here reaches a scorching 70 point 7
Celsius that's almost double the
temperature of your body so I guess that
begs the question who is the poor
scientist who had to sit out here with a
thermometer and take a reading every day
I hope they had a fridge at least well
we know scientists can do some pretty
crazy things sometimes but no one is
that crazy the data actually comes from
a NASA satellite called aqua that
monitors the mungo of things the heat
radiation of the Earth's surface from
2003 to 2010 the satellite would image
the entire planet every one to two days
giving us data on temperatures clouds
winds and much more the local name for
the desert is Gundam Berlin which means
roasted grain the story is that
traveling farmers spilt their seeds on
the Sun and within just a few days it
was scorched and ruined by heat before
it could be collected not that you guess
a lot of people traveling through it's
certainly no picnic out there but people
do come to see the beautiful of a
worldly Sun castles in the western
corner of the desert
the erosion has carved teetering towers
that make it seem like some lost ancient
city right so if that got you feeling a
little hot under the collar let's all
cool off by heading in the opposite
direction the coldest place on earth the
lowest recorded temperature is minus
eighty nine point two degrees Celsius
taken in 1983 at the Soviet Vostok
station but the station was just there
to make these measurements so you know
the scientists were being paid to be
there in cold hard cash
very cold hard cash but imagine if your
whole town chose to live like this ome
AB con is the oldest permanent
settlement on earth with some 500 people
living in freezing temperatures open the
northeastern tip of Russia in winter it
has got as low as minus sixty seven
point seven degrees and typically
averages minus forty five Celsius in
December and January the craziest thing
is that unlike Antarctica where you're
lucky if you ever get above minus 30
Celsius even in summer
ome akan has hit plus thirty four point
six degrees Celsius in July and normally
averages around 20 C for the summer
months imagine trying to buy a yearly
wardrobe that covered a difference of a
hundred Celsius enough about temperature
we're moving on to new heights or just
really high heights so what is the
world's highest point now this seems
like quite an obvious one right the
highest point must be the highest
mountain which is yep that's right
Mount Everest in the Himalayas but when
we say that highest mountain what do we
really mean well we mean that every
speak is 8,848 meters above sea level an
over mountain can match that but if you
measure from the base to the peak which
is quite hard to do because there isn't
some nice red line that says the
mountain starts here then actually the
tallest mountain is Mount Mount aquella
at
massive 10200 of three meters but it's
deep in the Pacific Ocean the first six
thousand meters of Mauna Kea are the
water so it doesn't really help us to
find the world's highest point let me
introduce
Chimborazo okay I know it's only six
thousand two hundred and sixty-seven
meters above sea level but here's a
twist its peak is the furthest away from
the center of the earth of any mountain
you know that globe you had in geography
class that was a perfect sphere
well the earth isn't actually like that
it bulges around the equator so the land
and the sea level are actually a few
kilometers higher at these points than
anywhere else
since Chimborazo is in Ecuador named for
being right on the equator it gets this
little boost from the Earth's bulge so
it's actually six thousand three hundred
and eighty four point four kilometers
from the center of the earth which beats
Everest it's six thousand three hundred
and eighty two point three kilometers
from the Earth's center in your face at
risk you so that's the highest
point but what about the lowest the
lowest place on the Earth's surface is
the Dead Sea it's not really a sea it's
more a really salty lake fifty
kilometers long in 15 wide and it lies
almost half a kilometer below sea level
429 meters to be exact it gets its name
from the almost total lack of aquatic
life there you're more likely to find
chips in it than fish in salt quantity
is so high that swim it's just float on
the surface like a human inflatable but
if we don't stick to the Earth's surface
we can find places much deeper in the
Pacific Ocean just south of Japan there
is Marianas Trench and its lowest point
is called challenger deep and bottoms
out at ten thousand nine hundred and
sixteen meters below sea level
here the pressure reaches over a
thousand times what it is at the surface
so unless you happen to be an
invertebrate or of a soft bodied
organism you will probably end up a soup
under the immense pressure that deep
underwater have you ever had that
feeling when you're at the top of a
really high building or say a waterfall
you wonder what it would feel like if
you jumped well you're not alone it's
often called the high plays phenomenon
and some psychologists think it's your
brain getting confused by the feeling of
dizziness and vertigo even though no
realistic threat is being posed so
imagine what it would feel like if you
took a trip to the top of Mount for the
world's greatest vertical drop this
gigantic cliff face can be found on
Baffin Island in Canada and boasts a
1,250 meter vertical drop it will take
the average person over 15 seconds to
reach the bottom if they jumped off it
and because the world is a crazy place
people do jump off it in fact Baffin
Island has become something of a hot
spot for base jumpers who braved the
arctic conditions on polar bears to hop
in a wingsuit and scream Geronimo as
they take a wild plunge from Falls Peak
the force of doing one of those jumps
makes my mouth go dry do you know where
else would do that the driest place on
earth
then the west coast of South America
tucked behind the Andes lies a 1000
kilometer strip called the Atacama
Desert it's so dry that it only receives
around 15 millimetres of rain every year
and as little as one millimetre in some
parks that means if you spit on the
ground you're giving it more moisture
than it'll see all year this isn't just
the recent recordings either geologists
believe that it's been like this for
some 200 million years so you never know
an Argentinosaurus could have come along
and dribbled on the exact same dry spot
surprisingly the land isn't completely
barren and some plants and animals do
exist mainly around the edges of the
desert and some years if you do enough
rain dances and manage to get over the
usual 15 millimeters of precipitation
then huge areas of the desert burst into
color a variety of seeds in bulbs lay
dormant through the dry years but come
alive in a visual symphony when the
rains do finally return when discussing
dry places we should also mention the
Dry Valleys in Antarctica in an enormous
continent of whiteness these are
certainly a strange sight
permanently ice-free valleys well they
do have a very small number of frozen
lakes but it's mainly just heart
great-looking dirt the reason it's so
dry is due to katabatic winds the
surrounding mountains block the flowing
guys and then when cold air comes over
the top
the gravity pulls it down words making
it rip through the valleys it's up to
320 km/h this heats the air and
evaporates all the ice and snow this
windows are whips up tiny stones and Sun
blasts the boulders into these beautiful
carvings that look like enormous
dinosaur skeletons it gives it the
feeling of being in an alien world and
in fact because of their alien like
features both the Dry Valleys of
Antarctica and the Atacama Desert are
used to test various NASA projects such
as the Rovers for Mars and one of
Jupiter's moons Europa if you want to
escape these dry sci-fi landscapes we're
better than the world's wettest place
more syndrome a village in northeastern
India holds the Guinness world record as
the world's wettest place with a current
average of eleven thousand eight hundred
and seventy-two millimeters per year to
give you some perspective that's ten
times what rainy old England normally
averages the cause of all this rain is
related to the Kazi Hills which are
placed right in the path of airflow that
comes from the Bay of Bengal one key
factor is that the air coming over the
hills create uplift and cooling which
increases the condensation so it's like
you're constantly pumping the clouds
full of more water the title of world
wettest plate is actually contested by
two towns in Colombia euro and puerto
lopez euro had an average of thirteen
thousand two hundred and ninety nine
millimeters of rainfall for a few years
in the 1950s but the equipment was
pretty outdated so we don't know how
much we can trust these figures as for
puerto lopez
although it has decent records to show a
twelve thousand eight hundred and ninety
two millimeter precipitation average
there are some mom's missing in the
middle of fifty years of data so
unfortunately they cannot claim a title
seems a bit harsh but hey if you're
sitting inside all day
you should have time to do your filing
properly if you forgotten your umbrella
maybe we should look for somewhere else
for you to go how about the world's
highest permanent settlement this honor
goes to La Rinconada in the Peruvian
Andes it sits at the bottom of the
Sleeping Beauty Gracia and there's a
whopping five thousand one hundred
meters above sea level it has a pretty
stable climate and is typically a degree
or two above freezing all year round so
what's the appeal for the 50,000 or so
inhabitants well it's one of mankind's
old loves gold never gold mines nearby
and this is where almost all of the
economy comes from but the way workers
are paid is very strange
most are part of the castle yo system
this means they go 30 days unpaid and
then on the 31st day they can take as
much or as they can carry and hope that
they find gold in it it's a complete
lottery of course but it's coming
practice to pocket a promising looking
stone even when it's not Casserly O'Day
as well as the peculiar payment system
the city is not the safest place either
there is no plumbing or sanitation
system and since mercury is used in the
Gulf of Fineman process the water is
pretty contaminated but hey who needs
toilet 2 non-toxic water if you've got
yourself some shiny shiny gold and
finally if you really really want to get
away from it all you need to head down
to the most remote inhabited place on
earth around 300 people live on the
island of Tristan da Cunha which is
2,000 kilometers from its nearest
neighbors on the island of st. Helena
that's a long way to paddle if you need
to tell them to turn the music down the
Nevis continental land is South Africa
some 2,400 kilometers away it's actually
a small cluster of islands one is
uninhabitable there's some are just
wildlife reserves but the main island
where people live is 98 kilometers
squared and these people are members of
the British Commonwealth the island was
discovered by the Portuguese Admiral
Tristan da Cunha in 1506 but was only
used as a stop off point for merchants
and whalers until the early nineteen
the British declared it part of its
Empire in 1860 due to two main concerns
firstly during the war with the United
States the u.s. used it to launch
attacks on British merchant fleets and
secondly it was to stop Napoleon from
escaping from st. Helena Napoleon had
already escaped once before from a
prison on Elba near Italy so after the
Battle of Waterloo the British took no
chances and sent him as far away as they
could from anyone the navy on Tristan da
Cunha would patrol the waters and look
out for any French attacks once Napoleon
died from arsenic poisoning he got from
his wallpaper the fleet decided to stay
there and so the island has been
inhabited ever since it was briefly
evacuated in 1961 when the island
volcano Queen Mary's peak erupted they
have their own economy largely from
renting out their out land fishing
waters they also sell unique coins and
postage stamps that are something of a
collector's item since it's hard to
trade when you live 2,000 kilometres
away from everyone most of their
suppliers come from eight to nine times
a year from South African fishing boats
it makes ordering off Amazon a bit of a
slow process they do have internet
access now though since an internet cafe
opened up in 2006 but the internet is so
slow on the island that when someone
wants to Skype a relative the entire
island has to turn off their internet
access to free or bandwidth seriously
the world certainly is full of extreme
places that push the limits and boggle
of mind but unless you want to be
incredibly hot perishing lis cold or
nerving lehigh incredibly dehydrated
completely soaked or just really really
far from anyone then you're probably
best off seeing right where you are
thanks for the view subscribe for more